this week we got shortest marathon
crossbow tooth fairy and deadly habit
that's a new I think that's the best one
yeah like going hey it's game show we do
it again welcome back the weekends grant
it changed Steve green lovely tiff and
today we're gonna talk about hmm
raise your edge Tooth Fairy what was it
Wow good nice mugging alright so for our
first story there's this Texas town
named horn that are holding their first
annual point 5k run point 5k what's
point five K what is that like the
[ __ ] 20 feet 500 yards oh how far is
that 500 that's like from here to the
end of the room that's like one lap
what's five feet five football fields
but it's oh it's five football fields
like a hundred yards or five of them or
it's like a hundred yards more than like
one lap they're saying that it should
take no more than ten minutes
same week so for these people for who
for those sign up people
I'm I'm at in it yeah so is this for
charity call and local charities also
you should take no more than two minutes
to complete
I mean if you're really talking about no
just for like if you don't finish in two
minutes you need to check yourself what
if you're just walking then they need to
kill you for two minutes to run back and
forth five times out of in a floor even
think you can do that what two minutes a
point 5k yeah I don't think you can do
it in to me but that's five laps back
and forth or or let's go get us a GoPro
can we get back we have Barbara I don't
think you can do it in two minutes but
football can you put it this way the
football player which is a elite athlete
right a 40-yard dash is under five
seconds you have a doesn't want fool
people yeah
so the whole thing is under ten seconds
yeah but how many football players could
run full-speed back and forth five times
that's a little different they can do it
no cuz I see like Dez Bryant charge down
the field right but it's only a hundred
yards yeah but he can do it like two
times and he could spend the
of one minute and 45 seconds crawling do
you think everyone signing up to this
are football players no that's not one
thing
I'm just saying 10 minutes is a long
time for I think I don't think you can
do it when you're you're not and I like
to bar on the track let's cut to I don't
think I could do it because I remember
this in two minutes so what I do
remember is this and the reason why I
stand behind my numerical guarantee is I
remember in sixth grade Olympics and I'm
a slow runner I ran the 400-yard and 54
seconds that's under a minute how do you
remember dad I'm a because running a
team yes because I was like what a [ __ ]
I was but and then sixth grade I was
probably three feet tall that I believe
that that number I've been I ran that in
54 seconds all right why you got a [ __ ]
on this it's for charity and it's
products for people that have never
moved in their [ __ ] life I thought
it's full troll troll 'ti no sounds like
but it's like your charity train oh it's
a troll oh it's a bit it's a bit yep
that's Paul rust right it's promoting oh
that's that control that's that's what I
thought it was like it's a big [ __ ]
joke world's shortest merit like run or
whatever how do you like [ __ ] on
comedy now Bart I love it called
blessings in a backpack where they feed
they feed kids like student yeah not the
food the backpack I don't know the
[ __ ] kid get ready for the six inch
run it's the half a foot run there you
go yeah I like it
so that would be funny I'm gonna buy
shoes the whole [ __ ] outfit do it
yeah why get out of bed
why can't you just roll over once in bed
and get charity money yeah why these
participants at the so be paid a $25
entry fee they get a free beer at the
beginning and a free beer at the end
that's the price of it they have a
doughnut and coffee hydration station at
sauce and then they'll they'll also get
a t-shirt Andy that's why it's ten
minutes cuz it gets around halfway
through it I think it's genius
I think it's it's effective it's going
out to do what it needs to do so yeah
we've already reached capacity right so
it's getting it's getting the the people
that would never do this yeah and
they're gonna feel good about themselves
they're gonna participate they're like
cool I'm gonna do some fitness [ __ ] it's
not overly I'm not intimidate this ideal
person so I can picture she's picturing
a fat [ __ ] no Steve would do it thank
you
5k I would do it if I was on like a dirt
bike because I feel like what five cares
more than what you would want to do
anyway but you would do it like if Nicky
was like I want to do it then you're
like oh yeah I mean if Nikki yeah yeah I
think you were doing good this is not
intimidating right but if it was a 10k
you're like nah I love you baby but
here's the thing Nikki and I have a deal
where if I do something and that she
makes me to do I have the right to
complain about it the entire time and
that's that you would do a 10k
absolutely not right exactly but you
would probably do this cuz it's not it
yeah we do it for the bigger I'd be in
it for the beer you see yeah and that's
gene how many miles is a ten if I I
don't know these [ __ ] European or 10k
I think [ __ ] do they use these 10k is
like seven eight miles it's like twenty
four litres so like okay so 5k is half
of that 5k three miles mmm a little bit
over three miles why so is it like these
five Kanak 10k and then they go marathon
yeah they usually build up to it or
whatever do you know the numbers like
what are the numbers isn't it like
20-something 26 I know what the marathon
number is but this 26 of the kappa
marathon is like 13 why can't they do a
cakewalk for charity that's what's up
this is what they're trying to do no no
but I'm an even simpler you keep it into
one room yeah sixteenths have a flip
marathon I mean but have you done a
cakewalk
what's a cakewalk it's a blast I don't
even do charity walks [ __ ] that here let
me let me let me bring you in I just
give money let me bring you into my
white world
okay we're you're all I feel better
already
thank you you're in a big circle and
like a gymnasium okay everyone stands on
a number and everyone they're brought a
cake a pretty dope looking cake right
okay yeah and it's like musical chairs
when you stop on the number and they say
okay stop that's the cake that you get
to the corresponding number it and then
you just go pick up the cake it's the
[ __ ] best thing ever
then how does that benefit homeless
people yeah what is it for I know you
buying tickets to the cakewalk
oh and that money goes to the chip oh so
it's like a musical chair but then you
can win a cake I feel like this is that
but now we're in the era that Fitness is
like key like everyone's trying to get
hundred yards like I think you burned
that many calories chewy on cake I never
understood I never understood these like
walks like like aids walks Breast Cancer
Walk it's like how does walking I think
it's about ego at the core it's a
hundred percent cuz you know when people
I'm doing this for it's like we'll just
keep giving the money you [ __ ] it's a
load is it fun well cause I had
classmates that would be like would you
sponsor me for this [ __ ] breast
cancer awareness walk I'm like [ __ ] no
yeah it does get cubicle I did uh I'm
sponsoring [ __ ] I think I did up you got
give you money that's it or I did a
mental health one yeah you only
sponsored [ __ ] Girl Scouts because
you get the cookie lieutenants with the
Eagle right works like I'm doing the
training for this it's not about that so
you get I did one for mental health and
cause I'm gonna agree with this at all
today let's just get you outta here I'm
ready to fight let's let's just tell me
real quick before we move on to like I
need to know so it's it's actually about
getting the awareness out so when you do
it you have like a sign-up sheet right
like hey let me get ten sponsors or 20
sponsors do this thing so as you talk to
people
hey Ryan would like to sponsor me I'm
gonna do this thing you get to spread
this awareness so when you have like 100
people doing it and they all talk to 10
people it becomes a thousand and then
when they book like the streets to go
and do it they have like all these
posters and stuff so it creates like
this big visual thing you lost me in
awareness listen there's
so many runs walks jogs for blah right
yeah you want awareness put me in a
[ __ ] dunk tank no put me in a white
like one of those motorcycle suit things
you can have me go through a flaming
Ring cycle through a flaming [ __ ]
ring right yeah like a flaming that
where with a little mini cake for some
reason the Cape can't go over my back
yeah it's a miniature cake so it doesn't
hit the back tire icon with that that's
awareness that's what we're nasaan they
need to hire that's I like that that's
what I write you want to wear white
though or how about I'll skydive in like
a big fat sumo costume that's awareness
like something tight not everyone does
this [ __ ] everyone does the walks and
fries and [ __ ] the walks are kind of
played out
next story so there was this dad in
Vietnam that helped his son pull his
tooth out with bow and arrow a
motorcycle a scooter I know what a
scorpion a Lamborghini he tied a string
to his [ __ ] tooth and he tickled the
scorpion front and the tail whipped it
up can you guys give me the dialogue
like you you're the son you're the dad
and then give you the nub yeah you're
the guy give me the dialogue of what
happened daddy the tool is the loop I
have idea what you want to do do you
want to see us go up man no so he goes
to the river right and then he ties a
fish string on one tooth and then puts
like a [ __ ] catfish nugget on the end
and throws it in the water and when the
catfish catches that [ __ ]
it takes the tool what are you there for
four hours there's no Katherine there's
always catfish in Vietnam there always
is always every single lake every every
yeah
- it's like [ __ ] pigeons they got a
lot of catfish the pigeons of the CEO
are River
I like overkill I like overkill with the
tooth pull like attach it the string to
a back of a Lamborghini and like a
rocket no you know 120 and 3 3 seconds
that's a viral video right there right
let me tell you my parents try to do
that [ __ ] to me tied my tooth put it on
a door thing and every time they're
about to close it I went last minute
okay - they tried they tried to close it
but I was like ready for like you listen
here we go know what a kid that is a key
kid it's my [ __ ] phone dad can't
believe it work he's like holy [ __ ] is
so tight and the one his teeth looks
like that he shouldn't make it that fun
that kid wanna pull [ __ ] teeth bad ten
strings the worst thing that my parents
ever did was give me dimetapp which
tastes like grape soda oh yeah and I
just kept sneak in that [ __ ] cuz
that's like that pink medicine when you
get sick I couldn't wait to get six like
it down and now and now kids are like
like they made sour patch gummies and
[ __ ] like that are vitamins yeah
like kids are [ __ ] sneakin oh [ __ ] I
know I know a kid eating a whole hand I
hate a whole jar of the world yeah I
think David Aylor the whole thing and
got [ __ ] up from it yeah can you
imagine eating that many vitamins like
you grow a [ __ ] tail oh that's all I
gotta do yeah probably
biggest ever I actually read that it
because we're taking so many vitamins
we're taking like too many vitamins that
we're actually adding to our [ __ ]
tails I'm not interesting what tails I
don't think we have natural tails we
terrible you've already your tailbone
before sacrum no coccyx excuse me yeah I
forgot the coccyx that sounds like a
toxic [ __ ] they call it a coccyx it's
like with two [ __ ] bones last story uh
we have here a dad a dad nearly
okay so a dad nearly died from biting
his fingernails what are you talking
about do this to me you do of course
fine
that's why cuz I bone fingernail thank
you the groom no I mean I see them you
just tell me that you could bite that
you haven't yet well I will yeah so what
he did this dad here he's fathered cue
speaking like that today I don't know so
you heard huh I think it's a cat because
of their voice yeah she's [ __ ] gone
big
I don't appreciate it okay so this dad
here is be with Luke twenty eight years
from the UK he was biting his nails like
he always does yep but then in this
particular instance he did the scan off
the side of his nail too all the time so
he just ignored it but she needs to
relax
he got an infection which then spread to
the rest of his body so he got sepsis
and he's all [ __ ] he experienced
flu-like symptoms so it always feel like
bloody hell he didn't use neosporin I
mean obviously not I don't use neosporin
when I cut my shitty that you gotta use
neosporin he got bad luck too yeah this
is like when I read about people who
like Goodwin swimming in the lake and
some parasite called in their ass I'm
always like you can't do anything have
you heard about the lady who took out
her trash and then something kind of
sliced her like a small little cut and
then like they had to chop off her whole
[ __ ] leg
see what I'm saying it's like it's
always the weirdest little [ __ ] I was a
kid in Owen with my friend to the pool
and this is like the saddest most
funniest thing that happened to me we're
both excited to go to this pool we jump
in the pool I had a great splash my
friend it just so happened to be you
know the top of the coke can where
there's that little yeah he's somehow
landed on in a slice is foot are you
sitting with David no but I was just I
just thought it was so funny that like
we're so excited to go and if he jumps
and he gets his foot [ __ ] sliced open
so now he gets to watch me swim and I'm
just like having a good time you didn't
help your friend
no that's [ __ ] no but no you did a
little stay now like I always expect I
mean it's like like I swear you could
read a Daily Mirror article where it's
like this kid brushed his hair and it
was the worst mistake he ever made and
like he died because he brushed when I'm
in a plane I don't get scared anymore
cause I'm like if it's my time to go
it's my just guy right yeah I was
freaking out in Hawaii because oh yeah I
went into you know I love [ __ ] going
into freshwater there's a lake
minnetonka
like [ __ ] swimming and the flood
waters going in my mouth like I'm just
like the waterfalls come in I'm drinking
it I don't give a [ __ ] right and then I
climbed up
upstream and there's a dead [ __ ] rat
in there and then
and in the locals are like watch out for
rat lungworm disease ha ha ha
long worm [ __ ] parasite right and I'm
like no and your head you're cutting
back to you like like like all the water
right yeah taking a bath in it like
Washington Han yeah so basically these
[ __ ] parasites they exist in slugs
and then they go into rats and then they
[ __ ] kill them and then they go into
the water system and if you drink that
[ __ ] it goes up into your brain
to control your head like a zombie and
then you die that whole trip he thought
he had it yeah that's you oh yeah well
I'm not usually a [ __ ] hypochondriac
but that's your [ __ ] with my head you
are you are a little [ __ ] me man
but I I forget in a day oh it doesn't
make me leave it doesn't but you don't
die in a day you're a bunch of [ __ ] all
the time did you start to going are
these my thoughts three days straight
you're like are these are rats thoughts
are my thoughts knowing you you're like
wait I wouldn't think that why don't you
he's never saying yeah he got a mild
case yeah anyway this dude here in Luke
he spent four days in the hospital
that's so sad yeah somebody is [ __ ]
nails
that's this from biting his nails and
then he said that they like they were
cleaning out the wound and his finger
and that he think they just pushed out
all this puss he was like you know UK
nails are nasty too though like I don't
know if they're known for the hygiene
because they got like stinky breath and
like net nasty nails bad teeth is the
middle name though oh yeah so maybe that
his teeth in fact it is you're offending
so many people do I get such a weird
release seeing like pus squeezed out of
something it's like the zit pop it feels
good right it might feel good to watch
it yeah I feel that with just dirty
stuff getting clean
oh yeah like like a power washing yes
really that does nothing to me Wiki like
a squeegee a squeegee squeegee a window
that's really dirty and then they clean
it and one wipe is just clean I'm like
oh you must love infomercials he must
just [ __ ] me oh no
is he always clean I do like you just
watching a home shopping when they throw
this [ __ ] on the carpet and then in just
one sweep and it's like that perfect
like line and the rest around it is
dirty well they dear us something you're
like have you guys ever had those
salesmen go door-to-door and they come
to your house and then they [ __ ] just
start spraying your [ __ ] and doing like
an example so one can would you grow up
in the 1950s no one came to my house
recently
no no when I was a year old okay and
then my dad answered the door and I was
like oh who is it and then like he
[ __ ] did this thing how you don't
hate me soft man we solve an industry I
want to show you this new vacuum cleaner
like that kind of afraid he sprayed our
[ __ ] doormat and then that [ __ ] was
so different I was mind blowing like dad
we gotta [ __ ] get this [ __ ] I was
like I promise I'll clean if you get it
and he's all like you're gonna clean so
I so he actually bought it for me and I
would [ __ ] spray everything just so I
could scrub it out and see like the
difference and it blew my mind last time
yeah interesting
[Music]